à quelques kilomètres à peine du centre
de la capitale de rares indications que
le pays traverse un deuil national dans
ces rues de vie continue avec ses hauts
et ses bas particulièrement ces jours-ci
au Royaume-Uni l'inflation a augmenté de
plus de 10% en un an c'est le taux le
plus élevé de tous les pays du G7 les
impacts se font particulièrement en
sentir dans les quartiers comme celui-ci
dans le sud de Londres où le tiers de la
population vit sous le seuil de la
pauvreté
les connaît bien cinq jours par semaine
son organisme distribue environ 150
pages chauds dans des quartiers
défavorisés
le jour des funérailles
comme d'habitude les quartiers
défavorisés du sud de Londres pour
distribuer de la nourriture férié ou pas
de nombreux londoniens dans le besoin
auront faim
dans ces quartiers la relation avec la
couronne est parfois compliquée
que de nombreux résidences sont des
descendants venus d'Afrique ou des
Caraïbes plusieurs anciennes colonies
dont certaines ont toujours des liens
avec la monarchie et où on évoque encore
les compensations qui devraient être
versées pour les impacts de ce passé
colonial
ces pays sont pauvres la Grande-Bretagne
devrait leur rendre de leur richesse
dit-elle des revendications qui n'ont
pas empêché anti-asmidt d'attendre
plusieurs heures pour se recueillir
devant le cercueil d'une reine qu'elle
respectait
c'est pour plusieurs dans le quartier
des cérémonies ne sont pas au cœur des
priorités l'immense couverture
médiatique rend les événements
difficiles à ignorer
a bien sûr vu les images des kilomètres
d'attentes pour accéder à Westminster
plusieurs heures pour participer aux
hommages la réalité d'un Royaume-Uni qui
deuil royale ou non n'a pas le luxe de
s'offrir une pause il se rappelle
Bouvier au clair Radio-Canada à Londres